All right, let's follow up about the situation
in Bolivia.
We are seeing effectively the worst a
possible outcome of the resignation of former
Bolivian president Evo Morales taking place
right now, which is that an absolutely bonkers
religious nut supported by some of the worst
extremist right-wing fascistic ideologues,
uh, has apparently succeeded at seizing power,
at least temporarily in Bolivia, literally
showing up with Bible in hand and racist comments
to boot.
I'm talking about Janine [inaudible] Chavez.
She's a Senator.
She said she's taking power and her power
grab is being recognized by the United States,
by Russia and by many others and she's a completely
bonkers religious zealot racist.
Now let, let's go back before we get into
the details.
Many of you appreciated my commentary a couple
of days ago about Bolivia where I tried to
explain in the best way I know that a lot
of black white interpretations of Latin American
politics by people in the United States fall
short.
And that, uh, as someone who is from Argentina
and has seen, um, uh, how my family was affected
by a military dictatorship and this sort of
balancing or, or shift that happens between
supposedly left wing populace to become authoritarians
and, uh, military dictatorships and all of
this stuff.
It's a pattern that is very common in Latin
America.
The United States has some to do with that,
but it's not solely responsible and that any
black white interpretation of this is merely
the fault of the United States.
This is simply a, uh, a populist hero.
This is simply a military coup.
None of these analyses are going to accurately
portray what is taking place in Bolivia or
in most of these situations in, in Latin America.
So a lot of people appreciated my commentary
of course, as expected.
I was quote, ratioed by people who are just
absolutely furious with me.
And you know, I'm a shill.
Uh, my family was pro dictatorship in Argentina.
That's absolutely insane allegation to make
all of that stuff, but I don't care.
I'm just going to keep doing this story the
way I see it.
And hopefully there is some value, uh, for
most of the people in the audience.
So, um, the racist religious zealot Senator
shows up and says, I assume the presidency
immediately and we'll do everything necessary
to pacify the country.
A Bolivian constitutional court almost backs
her assumption of power.
The United States backs it.
As I mentioned, Russia backs it and other
countries do and it is very quickly getting
extremely ugly.
Number one, she's a straight up racist tweeting
some years ago.
I'll, I'll read this in Spanish and then I'll
translate it for you shortly.
Swen yokozuna Bolivia [inaudible] LASU that
[inaudible] seniors [inaudible] Oh, I'll Choco
my translation is I dream of a Bolivia free
from the sights Hannah essay, tannic rituals
of indigenous people.
[inaudible] of course, the first indigenous
president of Bolivia.
The city isn't for Indians who should go to
the plateau or to the Chaco, which is a like
a rural region in Bolivia.
So this is already disgusting, but it gets
even worse.
She showed up holding an oversized Bible.
What looks oversized to me, I guess I'm not
an expert in Bible sizes, but it looks like
this one is comically large walking towards
the presidential palace, holding it.
Take a look at this.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] LA [inaudible] is
better.
It's embargo, the official [inaudible].
So again, if you were in the group that responded
to my commentary a couple of days ago saying,
David, Oh my you, you're for the cool.
Come on.
I told you I am not going to participate in
the talking points of either side on this.
I don't want militaries forcing people in
or out.
I recognize the corruption of able Morales
and the sketchiness of his finding a way to
stay in power 13 years when upon being elected
to that term.
The initial term he was entitled to.
I don't remember now if it was a five or a
six year term.
Sorry if I have the numbers mixed up, but
I also don't want this.
It's sort of like, I believe that the Chavez
regime of Venezuela, Hugo Chavez and Nicolas
Maduro have raped and pillaged the country
and its resources for their gain.
But I don't want the United States installing
some neoliberal clown puppet there.
How are both possible?
Well, because I have no interest in applying
a, um, inappropriate or insufficient black
white standards that make no sense for the
situations that are far more complicated than
that.
So listen, if, uh, a Chavez and I'm talking
about the, the new a president interim president
Janine on, yes Chavez.
If she runs in an election in the next 90
days in which she is not a candidate and it
is a free and fair election, okay, then we
might have something to talk about here.
If she doesn't and, or if she is herself a
candidate in an election that she oversees
after seizing the interim presidency, then
we have a problem and we'll be following it.
And of course regardless, we have a problem
anyway because this is an absolutely disgusting
person to be taking control in Venezuela,
in Bolivia, so you know, a, as far as the
reactions of people saying that this is simply
a military coup or this is simply the peaceful
and uncoerced resignation of the Bolivian
president.
This is neither of those things.
This is a much more complicated situation.
One of the main supporters, by the way, it's
[inaudible].
We should mention one of the main supporters
of the resignation of Evelyn Mondelez is a
complete and total fascist.
You have lunatics trying to swoop in.
Louis Phaedra, none.
Low Camacho is a far right fascist extremist
who has wanted Ava one out is out for awhile
and it is absolutely and utterly toxic and
disgusting, but what people have to understand
is that, and I don't know if I'm doing a good
enough job of making this clear, these situations
cannot possibly be interpreted as good slash
bad simple military coup versus not at all
right?
The reality is much more complex.
This is unfortunately the neverending quagmire
of Latin American politics.
People claiming to be leftist populists, get
into power, become authoritarians when they
got elected, and, uh, use or manipulate the
system in order to stay in power longer than
they are actually supposed to at the time
of the election.
But then income the fascists to push them
out while claiming to be better, but actually
being terrible and in and out in and of themselves.
And meanwhile, this is the saddest thing.
The populations are the ones that suffer.
We've seen it in various forums in Venezuela,
in Argentina, in Shelia, and you've got Agua
or Nunez, Bolivia, Brazil.
Uh, we've seen this time and time again and
you know, not, not to make this now about
Argentina, but it's maybe the situation.
I know best.
Uh, listen, my family was not pro dictatorship.
My family was not, uh, the privileged academic
white people.
We left Argentina cause we had no money and
it was a, an absolute economic collapse in
1989.
Um, but it's sad to me when I see people who
say, you know, uh, the Kersner regime is going
to save us and it coming back is going to
save us.
No, it's not.
Or the alternatives that we have to the Kirshner
regime are what are going to save us, sadly,
know that the situation is much more complex
and to see people fighting and, and you know,
family relationships being lost over it, when
in the end, either way, there is not going
to be an improvement with the options that
are presented, a measurable, serious improvement.
It's very, very sad.
And a lot of the same is going on here in
Bolivia.
So I don't have a prescription.
Uh, I'm merely going to try to tell it to
you as I see it and disagree with me or agree
with me.
Um, these are my genuine opinions.
These are not my carefully crafted and, and,
uh, uh, calculated opinions in order to support
or attack a particular group or contingency.
Let me know your thoughts on Twitter at D
Pacman.
Remember that on Thanksgiving, we will be
emailing everybody on our newsletter list
with our huge big lead, tremendous year end
membership special.
Get on our newsletter@davidpakman.com if you
want to be notified of that